hablamos de salud en France 24 y por
ello me acompañan el estudio mi
compañera Natalia plazas Natalia
bienvenida Buenos días Valentina Buenos
días vamos a empezar con salud
reproductiva en Estados Unidos porque
las autoridades sanitarias de ese país
aprobaron por primera vez en la historia
que una píldora anticonceptiva se pueda
vender sin prescripción médica sí
Valentina se trata de un hito en la
contracepción en la historia del país en
norteamericano la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de Estados
Unidos aprobó por primera vez en su
historia que una píldora
anticonceptiva pueda ser vendida a las
mujeres que lo necesiten sin la
necesidad de presentar en las farmacias
una receta médica se espera que
concretamente la píldora o pila de la
compañía Perry Gold basada en dublín
este disponible en las farmacias de
Estados Unidos a partir de inicios del
año que viene recordemos que las
pastillas anticonceptivas que son
métodos que
ese métodos a base de hormonas que se
utilizan a lo largo del mes y que las
mujeres que los toman deben ir tomando
una pastilla al mes los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades de
Estados Unidos indican que este método
es uno de los métodos anticonceptivos
que tiene un margen de error más bajo e
incluso las preservativos tanto para
hombres como para mujeres
los productores de la pastilla apuntan
que tiene una efectividad del 99%
siempre y cuando se sigan al pie de la
letra las instrucciones para
para tomar estas pastillas que tienen
pues como acabamos de indicar un plan
mensual no obstante pues se sigue hay
incluso otros métodos actualmente que
son que tienen unas que tienen una
capacidad de proteger más alta que estas
pastillas pero como vemos es uno de los
mecanismos más efectivos que existen
tanto en Estados Unidos como en otros
países sin duda es lo que usted estaba
diciendo Hay que seguir las indicaciones
de las de Pues de las pastillas de los
medicamentos porque de lo contrario el
margen de error puede aumentar Sí
también es una píldora que es conocida
como la mini píldora porque tiene una es
a base solamente de una hormona que es
la progesterona diferencia de otras
píldoras que se llaman las píldoras
combinadas que contienen que tienen
también la hormona de la del estrógeno
recordemos que la piel también es una
píldora que ya había sido aprobada que
fue aprobada desde hace más de 50 años
Solamente pues que ya se vendía en el
país pero siempre bajo una prescripción
médica un panel de especialistas de la
fda fueron los que aprobaron y aprobaron
unánimemente el uso de esta píldora por
considerar que sus beneficios son mucho
mayores que sus riesgos sin embargo la
fda sí quiso
recalcar que hay algunos riesgos para
pacientes y concretamente destacamos
por ejemplo para las mujeres que tengan
o hayan tenido cáncer de mama u otros
tipos de cáncer que sean sensibles al
uso de la progesterona otras pacientes
en riesgo también son aquellas mujeres
que presenten sangrados uterinos
no diagnosticados por los médicos y
también para personas que tengan tumores
hepáticos es decir tumores de
hígado ya sean benignos o malignos
finalmente también aquellas mujeres que
sospechan estar embarazadas o que ya
pues hayan confirmado un embarazo
Natalia la compra sin prescripción de
estas píldoras anticonceptivas sin duda
facilita el acceso a métodos
anticonceptivos a quienes podría
beneficiar y pues ya se ha dicho algo
sobre su precio de distribución bueno
Valentina
los expertos que aprobaron esta píldora
lo que indican es que va a beneficiar
principalmente adolescentes a mujeres
jóvenes pero sobre todo a todas aquellas
mujeres que no tengan actualmente un
seguro médico y que por lo tanto le sea
más difícil acudir a un médico y también
adquirir una receta médica hasta el
momento no se sabe exactamente qué costo
tendrá este medicamento Pero lo que sí
que ha dicho pero ego es que están
buscando hacer unos costos bastante
asequibles para todas las mujeres y
incluso están pensando en hacer algunos
programas que puedan brindar estas
estos métodos anticonceptivos de manera
gratuita entre tanto hay Defensores de
los derechos reproductivos que están
pidiendo que estas píldoras sean
cubiertas por los seguros médicos del
Estado Ya que actualmente del estado y
privados ya que actualmente la ley que
regulariza la salud en Estados Unidos
obliga a los seguros médicos a cubrir
estas
estas recetas de anticonceptivos pero
hasta el momento no dice nada de estas
de estos planes anticonceptivos que
puedan adquirirse sin receta médica en
ese sentido el gobierno demócrata de el
presidente Joe biden y algunos senadores
en el congreso están presionando para
que justamente las legislación ampare
también estas estos métodos de
planificación sin receta veamos lo que
dice una de las principales impulsoras
de este proyecto en el senado Estados
Unidos
proporcionemos a las mujeres lo que
necesitan y asegurémonos de que sea
asequible para que haya equidad y que
las mujeres de bajos ingresos las
mujeres que por cualquier razón están
luchando no tengan por qué ser obligadas
a no tener ningún método anticonceptivo
Simplemente porque no pueden pagarlo
bueno y no dejamos de lado esta noticia
que ha causado revuelo en la industria
alimenticia Y es que la OMS declaró al
edulcorante aspartamo como posible
cancerígeno para los humanos Qué
significa Esto bueno Valentina como
venían anunciando el anuncio lo hizo la
agencia internacional de investigaciones
contra el cáncer que forma parte de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud esta
agencia concluyó que sí existe evidencia
científica de que el aspartamo puede
llegar a causar cáncer entre los humanos
pero catalogó a esta sustancia dentro de
las últimas categorías de sustancias que
podrían ser cancerígenas y que podrían
pues causar estas Este tipo de dolencias
entre la población esto concretamente
significa que si el aspartamo puede
causar cáncer tiene un riesgo de
inseguridad bajo de acuerdo a las dosis
que se utilizan diariamente y
normalmente entre la población en ese
sentido el comité de expertos mantuvo
una recomendación que ya existe desde
los años 80 y es no consumir más de 40
gramos por kilo de peso en las personas
diarios de este edulcorante recordemos
que es una sustancia que también es muy
presente en la industria en miles de
productos que hay muchos refrescos Bajos
en calorías yogures e incluso pastas de
dientes que contienen este
estas sustancia tras la noticia también
ha habido llamados de algunos expertos
de que por dejar de que por el miedo que
pueda causar esta noticia Las personas
no cambian el aspartamos por un
incremento del consumo de azúcar porque
ya también se ha probado que es muy
perjudicial para la salud y que sin
embargo contemplen vías más saludables
como puede ser el consumo
un mayor consumo de agua en vez de
refrescos que es pues una opción mucho
más saludable Valentina